valérie pécresse est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir ça et merci d'être avec
nous pour ce rendez-vous de public sénat
avec l' agence france-presse et c'est
nadège plus jack aujourd'hui qui vous
interrogera sur l'installation de
nicolas sarkozy que vous avez soutenu à
la tête de l'ump
dailymotion nous accompagne également
comme chaque semaine et perrine tarneaud
et là également nous la voyons creed
arnaud de public sénat qui elle vous
interrogera en tant que présidente du
groupe ump au conseil régional d'île de
france et j'ai vu que dans le nouvel
organigramme de votre parti valérie
pécresse vous êtes en charge de
coordonner cette campagne des régionales
dans un an maintenant même si vous êtes
déjà en campagne sur le terrain je suis
dans l'opposition active dans
l'opposition d'abord bien sûr le
soulagement après la libération de serre
de la saveur des hasards et beach la fin
d'un calvaire donc de trois ans pour le
dernier otages français dans le monde
la méthode hollande donc a fini par
obtenir un résultat que tout le monde
attendait je crois qu'il faut se réjouir
du retour des otages et se réjouir de ce
que l'état français ait fait le maximum
pour françois hollande aura quand même
là plusieurs libérations à son actif et
là il n'y a plus aucun de ces détenus
dans le monde
c'est vrai et il faut saluer aussi tout
le travail de nos diplomates et de nos
médiateurs il dénoncé la licence ce
difficile de saluer l'action du chef de
l'état valéry pétrole non mais je pense
que c'est effectivement vrai mais c'est
je le reconnais je mens je m'en félicite
et je ne fus de shit aussi de les avoir
libérés simplement je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
tellement grave pour tous les français
que c'est vrai que j'aurais aimé
j'aurais aimé beaucoup beaucoup de
choses de françois hollande s'était
alors il a été manifestement et la
portée par une bonne séquence à
l'international comme l'on dit on l'a vu
en guinée c'est le premier dirigeant
occidental à s'être rendus dans un pays
touché par ebola et puis à moscou il ya
eu 7 se rencontre impromptue pour avec
poutine oui cela fait plusieurs choses
positives oui c'est positif c'est vrai
maintenant il faut pas que ce soit un
fait pas il suffit pas d'une petite
rencontre entre deux portes ou d'un
crochet par moscou pour changer les
relations du tout au tout entre la
france et là aussi et je pense que cette
relation franco-russe
elle est absolument indispensable pour
résoudre toute une série
de conflit qui nous préoccupe au plus
haut point que ce soit en ukraine mais
aussi on sait bien au proche et moyen
alors dans la foulée de la libération de
notre otage dont qui était détenu depuis
trois ans je le disais par des
islamistes
il y a quand même une période de dangers
liés à la radicalisation manuel valls
vous accuse valérie pécresse de lui
tendre un piège en voulant empêcher le
paiement par autrui des amendes qui
frappe les femmes qui portent le voile
intégral dans notre pays que
répondez-vous au premier ministre vous
avez vous lu par habileté c'est aussi un
mot qu'il a utilisé lui tendre un piège
il y avait aucun piège dans ma question
moi je sollicitais là vous m'avez dit
que c'était que c'était difficile pour
moi de saluer l'action du président de
la république non mais là en revanche
c'était difficile visiblement pour le
premier ministre de soutenir une
proposition de loi que j'ai déposée pour
empêcher qu'il y ait détournement de la
loi anti voile intégral j'aime aller
voter en son temps que manet la salle
était un des rares socialistes à voter
et cette loi contre le voile intégral
c'est pas n'importe quelle loi c'est la
loi qui protège la dignité de la femme
qui refuse les fondamentalismes c'est
une loi qui est partie de notre pacte
républicain et cette loi est bafouée
elle est bafouée par un provocateur qui
a décidé d'aller payer systématiquement
les amendes des femmes qui ont été
verbalisés et moi je demandais concret
un délit d' entrave à la loi pour tous
ceux qui mettraient au point des
stratégies qui empêcherait les lois de
la culture une loi juste contre un homme
non non non non non c'est une loi qui
est générale c'est une loi qui
empêcherait toute une stout et
stratégies d' entrave à la loi c'est
très important aujourd'hui pourquoi
parce que la république allait défier lé
les fier à de nombreuses reprises elle a
été édifiée par exemple par l'humoriste
dieudonné quand il a fait un certain
nombre de spectacles dans lesquels il
il voit là on lui interdisait de déraper
il dérapé systématiquement mais comme il
n'ya pas de censure a priori il défiait
la république il ya toute une série de
moments où on voit la république être
défiée là en l'occurrence elle est défié
par ce provocateur dont je ne citerai
pas le nom pour pas lui faire de
publicité mais c'est aller défier par ce
provocateur qui va payer les amendes à
la place des femmes des femmes en voile
intégral et du coup évidemment on a des
femmes qui sont multirécidivistes et le
sentiment que cette loi anti burqa qui a
été voulu par la pl la représentation
nationale
elle est pas fou et et ça on ne peut pas
l'accepter quand la république recule
les extrêmes monde quand la république
recule le discrédit des politiques
augmentent c'était pas un piège il allie
manuel valls il aurait dû le comprendre
lui qui a toujours été très prompt à
défendre la laïcité d'entreprise alors
même l'oise a dévoilé à la fin de la
semaine un agenda de réformes c'est pour
la fin du quinquennat
est ce que vous êtes rassurés donc après
les pressions de bruxelles après
également les avertissements d'angela
merkel mais également de l'ump qui l'a
accusée de hollande isation voilà il va
donc mettre sur la table son agenda de
réformes
c'est une plaisanterie moi j'ai entendu
manuel valls il ya deux jours à la
télévision et qu'est-ce qui nous a dit
il nous a dit je veux durer
il nous a dit je veux rester jusqu'à la
fin du quinquennat mais on n'a plus du
tout entendu le mot réforme les réformes
elles font toutes shit la loi macron ya
plus de relèvement des seuils sociaux qu
attendait tellement d'entreprises
j'étais à midi avec une pme de 48
salariés qui m'a dit ah j'attends la loi
macron avec impatience je lis pas c'est
fini c'est fini
normalement il ya plus de relèvement des
seuils alors que c'était une promesse du
discours de politique générale du
premier ministre
le trail le dimanche on le bio va passer
de 5 à 12 et puis finalement les
socialistes disent on ramènera ce set
donc ça veut dire qu'on va passer de 5 à
7 donc vous voyez bien que c'est des
lois qui font pschitt la loi macron elle
christ le christ pas certain nombre de
professions mais elle ramènera pas la
croissance parce qu'elle n'est pas du
tout assez puissante donc tout cet
agenda de réformes est en train de
s'évaporer tout simplement l'utopie
réformatrice où l'euphorie réformatrice
de manuel valls est en train de
s'évaporer suis pas ce que vous y avez
cru donc à ba moi moi j'avais été de
ceux qui avaient dit s'il ya des choses
bonnes gelé voterai sans état d'âme
surtout en matière économique je pense
que voilà il ya des sujets qui sont ni
de droite ni gauche si on parle de
réforme des retraites si on parle d'
équilibre budgétaire si on parle de 200
ballons de réformes que la gauche a fait
dans les grands pays en allemagne en or
en grande bretagne c'est la gauche qui a
fait ses réformes de structure donc si
manuel valls avait eu le courage de son
de ses discours et bien j'aurais voté un
certain nombre de choses mais ça n'est
pas le cas et je ne vous parle même pas
de la réforme territoriale
on s'y retrouve plus c'est petit mais
vous-même valérie pécresse vous êtes
favorable à combien de dimanche autorisé
pour les commerces dans notre pays c'est
10 12 tous mais moi d'abord je suis ce
serait pour quelque chose d'un système
très simple parce que je dans la loi
macron telle qu'elle est peut-être kelly
prévu toute une série d'autorisations a
demandé quand vous commencez à demander
des autorisations
vous n'avez qu'une seule certitude c'est
l'arbitraire et l'arbitraire c'est
injuste ça veut dire vous allez vous
retrouver comme mission d'humeur et par
dutreuil l'addition du préfet souvent
non mais parce que par exemple je vous
donne un exemple en ile de france que je
connais bien et vous avez aéroville près
de roissy qui est ouvert tous les
dimanches et vous avez garé au nord
villepinte qui n'est pas ouvert pourquoi
vous aviez l'allèle toutes les bisbilles
entre le bricolage et jardinage et
évidemment on retrouvait dans les
grandes enseignes de jardinage des
outils de bricolage puisque les magasins
de bricolage et et vous voyez on arrive
à des situations aberrantes
il se trouve que moi je suis l'élu d'une
ville qui est une ville de marché une
ville touristique versailles bon à
versailles tout est ouvert le dimanche
pourquoi est-ce qu'on condamnerait
d'autres villes qui ne sont pas à vis
des marchés qui ne sont pas du
touristique à mourir
le dimanche et à être ville morte et
pourquoi est ce que on crée des
injustices
moi je suis pour beaucoup de souplesse
beaucoup plus de liberté dans ce domaine
et je pense qu'en plus c'est une
question de croissance
je les ai vus avec mes étudiants si on
est payé double
monchi c'est sur la base du volontariat
moi je dis chiche en tous les cas vous
ne voyez aucun élément de relance dans
la loi macron qui sera présenté demain
en conseil des ministres si il ya comme
un ciment réalisation alors de certaines
professions six professions réglementées
moi j'ai reçu les notaires les huissier
les greffiers
j'ai rencontré les avocats le sujet
c'est une formidable occasion manquée si
l'occasion manquée il fallait faire un
pacte a un impact global il fallait en
profiter pour déjudiciariser le système
judiciaire nous avons aujourd'hui une
justice qui emboliser par toute une
série de contentieux qui prennent un
temps fou j'étais au tribunal de bobigny
la semaine dernière et de bobigny est un
tribunal qui doit malheureusement gérer
toute la misère du monde c'est l'un des
départements les plus criminogènes de
france et c'est aussi un département il
ya une grande souffrance sociale
eh bien ils sont en bonne idée avec des
permis de conduire
le permis à points ils sont emboliser
avec des affaires familiales
est ce que vous savez que pour constater
la séparation d'un couple
il faut une décision du juge aux
affaires familiales et que si vous
n'avez pas cette décision
vous ne pouvez pas postuler un logement
social séparer ces petites choses comme
ça mais qui nourrissent la vie qu'ils
font attendre les français parce qu'il
faut attendre des semaines qui en goal
is a justice et qui coûte très cher on
aurait fait un pacte avec les notaires
avec les huissiers avec les greffiers
pour leur confier de nouvelles missions
en échange d'une baisse des tarifs ou de
libéralisation à ce moment là tout le
monde aurait été content et on aurait
fait une vraie réforme
ce que je dis c'est que monsieur macron
n'était pas prêt et que il n'y a pas de
grande envergure et formatrice dans
alors ne croyez pas aux effets de sa loi
il est difficile de parieurs n'ai plus
de travail derrière plus de négociations
plus de temps plus de profondeur alors
il est difficile donc de verser dans
l'optimisme
quand on regarde par ailleurs tous les
indicateurs économiques mais à l'elysée
semble et ils en trouvent au moins trois
raisons d'espérer
la baisse du prix du pétrole c'est vrai
vu le niveau des taux d'intérêt est
également celui de l'euro est-ce que
selon vous cette combinaison des trois
facteurs peut faire croire à vous aussi
ce ne serait pas un redressement en vue
est ce que vous vous rendez compte à
quel niveau d'impuissance se trouve
françois hollande
il en est à se réfugier derrière des
décisions dont il n'est absolument ni
l'auteur ni même lui-même m c'est à dire
que la baisse du prix du pétrole
c'est pas eu lie la baisse de l'euro
c'est pas lui et la baisse des taux
d'intérêt
alors justement c'est intéressant
il n'est responsable de rien de tout
cela mais ce sont des facteurs
favorables
on est aujourd'hui sous morphine on est
aujourd'hui sous morphine on est comme
gelée dire un malade qui rentrent en
salle d'opération on est sous anesthésie
on a les taux d'intérêt très faibles qui
nous permettent d'emprunter un euro très
faible qui nous permet de payer moins
cher d'exporter donc on a aujourd'hui un
contexte très favorable
si on n'en profite pas pour faire des
réformes structurelles maintenant eh
bien on rate une occasion inouïe et
inespéré on laisse passer notre chance
et qu'est ce qu'il va se passer quand
les taux d'intérêt vont remonter parce
qu'un jour ils remonteront la banque
américaine centrale a décidé de les
remonter remonter ses taux à partir de
noël les taux un jour remonteront l'euro
un jour remontera le prix l'énergie un
jour remontera parce que le pétrole
n'est pas inépuisable qu'est ce qui va
se passer
eh bien on sera on sera plus sous
anesthésie et c'est là qu'on m'a opéré
on va opérer quand le malade le malade
ne sera plus sous anesthésie ce sera
beaucoup plus douloureux des réformes
tout de suite c'est ce que vous devez
maintenant parce que le contexte s'y
prête et si on les fait pas maintenant
et bien on en aura vraiment ce sera très
douloureusement
est-ce que vous avez noté le vent
docilité qui se lève en france à
l'encontre d'un gala merkel mais manuel
valls considère que les disciplines
européenne doivent être appliquées avec
intelligence et bien sûr il est la
phrase de jean luc mélenchon qui lui a
demandé à la chancelière de la firme et
comment est ce que vous réagissez je
crois qu'on ne peut pas parler comme ça
à son principal partenaire moi je
d'abord je crois beaucoup à la politesse
je pense que la pluie thèse c'est une
valeur c'est une question d'éducation
je considère qu'on n'a pas injurié un
partenaire de l'importance de
l'allemagne avec lequel on a fait tant
de choses et on a tant de choses à faire
donc injurié les gens c'est pas la
solution c'est grossier ça sert à rien
en revanche moi je souffre quand je vois
l'allemagne donner des leçons je souffre
et j'ai même j'aimerais vous donner
raison en même temps mais on voit la cap
a donné les verges pour se faire battre
on peut pas aller voir l'allemagne et
leur demander pendant trois ans trois
ans des sursis trois ans successives les
sursis et en même temps dire après avoir
fait prendre des vessies pour des
lanternes à madame merkel parce que le
gouvernement lui a promis des réformes
depuis trois ans manuel valls qui a
promis la réforme territoriale elle
n'existe pas on lui a promis une réforme
des retraites qui n'existe pas au l'a
promis une baisse des dépenses
budgétaires qui n'existe pas et après on
ne peut pas l'empêcher parler et de dire
qu'elle est déçue je veux dire il ya un
moment si on donne les verges pour se
faire battre et on a un retour de
bakbone non et c'est ce qui se passe
ailleurs mais en revanche c'est la
germanophobie et les insultes c'est pas
digne de nous une question sur lionel
jospin qui va faire son entrée au
conseil constitutionnel donc pour
remplacer jacques baron il a pour vous
la légitimité la droiture nécessaire
pour cette fonction il a l'expérience et
la légitimité pour cette fois sur choix
mais je trouve un peu paradoxal ce choix
parce que j'avais entendu dire françois
hollande mais à l'époque il était mue
par son antisarkozysme primaire et
viscérale j'avais entendu françois
hollande dire que lui président il y
aurait plus de politique au conseil
constitutionnel et qu'il souhaitait une
réforme du conseil constitutionnel est
ce que j'ai pu voir le président c'est
un peu paradoxal et c'est un peu à
contre-courant de je crois les ambitions
affichées par françois hollande mais
évidemment il s'agissait d'écarter
nicolas sarkozy c'était une bonne raison
pour ne pas politiser à l'époque le
principal et on va parler de l'ump
maintenant donc avec nadège pull jacques
de la fp nicolas sarkozy a rendu visite
ce mardi matin aux sénateurs de votre
parti qui vous le savez un sont dit-on
majoritairement fillonniste comme vous
valérie pécresse
paul bouffard
ils sont là les fillonnistes gérard
larcher bruno retailleau pour accueillir
leur nouveau président oublié l'épisode
copé fillon nicolas sarkozy veut
réconcilier séduire aussi un groupe ump
au sénat qui ne l'a pas toujours soutenu
applaudissements standing-ovation
pendant près d'une heure tranquille
évoque le rapprochement avec les
centristes les questions d'identité
nationale l'islam et met en garde les
sénateurs ump face à l'as vence du front
national dans les sondages à la sortie
des bruneaux retailleau et sur nicolas
sarkozy a compris la sagesse
sénatoriales il a compris que on a tous
souffert des divisions et qu' il était
là d'abord pour rassembler nous l'avons
indiqué qu' il y en avait marre des
gestions du passé et je pense que les
premiers signes qu'il a pu donner depuis
quelques jours depuis que il est
président de notre famille politique
vont dans le bon sens le rassemblement
d'abord le rassemblement c'est
fondamental et c'est je crois ce que
souhaitent tous mes amis sénateurs de
l'ump
pour catherine frot cassia nicolas
sarkozy devra prendre encore plus en
considération la chambre haute
on ne peut pas dire qu'il a beaucoup
parlé du sénat et gérard larcher et lui
a rappelé qu'il ne fallait pas que le
sénat soit oublié comme il l'a été une
certaine période où ce sont les députés
qui dessinaient tout est compris sur la
réforme territoriale alors qu'ils sont
pas les premiers concernés
pour d'autres il faut rester vigilant
j'ai envie de dire il n'a pas changé
il sait ce qu'il veut pour ma part
j'attends un petit peu d'épreuves de sa
volonté d'ouverture de modération aussi
de respect des diversités
par contre il a été moins claire j'ai
trouvé sur les primaires et je le
regrette un peu parce que je crois que
c'est un rendez vous démocratique avec
l'ensemble des français qui pourra être
une étape importante de reconstruction
de l'ump pas très clair sur les
primaires pour 2017
nicolas sarkozy l'a dit il abordera le
sujet après les régionales dans un an
voilà même pécresse nous avons entendu
famille caire a l'air très inquiète sur
la primaire parce que nicolas sarkozy a
dit ce matin aux sénateurs nous
organiserons la primaire après les
élections locales les élections locales
c'est décembre n'est ce pas
les dernières les régions c'est en
décembre show l'an prochain à la fin de
l'année prochaine ce que dira qu' on
organisait plus honnête ou encore après
donc on a nos principes ya une petite
inquiétude là il va y avoir une primeur
ou pas mais je comprends pas le
fondement de cette inquiétude puisque
nicolas sarkozy vient de nommer thierry
solère à la tête d'un groupe qui
organisera justement les primaires et
sabbath commencé à travailler dès
maintenant ce que nicolas sarkozy a sans
doute voulu dire et alors là pour le
coup c'est que c'est une préoccupation
que je partage totalement et on est un
certain nombre à la partager
c'est que la priorité de 2015 c'est les
élections locales c'est les élections
locales pour lesquelles nous avons
besoin de nous rassembler le temps de la
primaire y vient après et tous ceux qui
ont des ambitions pour la primaire et
ils sont nombreux à l'ump ça vous a pas
échappé mais tous ceux qui ont des
ambitions pour la primaire doivent les
mettre en sourdine parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le temps du rassemblement
et moi je dirais même j'irai même plus
loin je dirais aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons plus nous permettre le luxe de
la désunion
aujourd'hui si vous le permettez et sans
aller trop loin
je dirais que pour l'ump c'est s'unir ou
prendre le risque de mourir et gestion
clanique 1 c'est ce que dit c'est
d'ailleurs monsieur retailleau un mail à
vihiers la main et bruno avec sa sagesse
sénatoriale à bono retailleau a très
bien dit ce que je pense je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus se
permettre le luxe et division les
électeurs non peuvent plus hier j'aurais
unisciel comité départemental des
militants des yvelines ses revenus en
permanence
ils ne veulent plus la guerre des chefs
ils ne veulent pas non plus de la guerre
en dessous ils ne veulent plus de guerre
du tout ils veulent qu'on soit unie
derrière un président qui est légitime
et aujourd'hui - chances d'élection du
président là il est j'y tiens je dis ça
avec des avec des militants qui ont
peut-être voter le maire qui ont
peut-être voter mariton qui ont
peut-être pas voté sarko si tu t'oublies
qui aujourd'hui considèrent qu'il faut
vous voulez vous attaquer aux ambitions
le des candidats à la primaire vous
l'avais dit à françois fillon vous allez
j'ai tout à fait dit à françois fillon
qu'aujourd'hui il fallait jouer
collectif et que nous devions prendre le
parti d'une race justement là nicolas
sarkozy a été élu e s ne lui
pardonnerait pas est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui l'ump un patron ça y est
l'union est en marche
c'est ce que vous dites aujourd'hui je
dirais qu'au jour
nicolas sarkozy ne ménage pas ses
efforts pour essayer pour rassembler
autour de lui ça il faut lui en donner
acte je le vois aujourd'hui travailler
je le vois consulter je le vois recevoir
des parlementaires qui sont proches mais
aussi les parlementaires très éloignées
et je pense qu'il fait ce travail de
rassemblement maintenant vous savez bien
ce que c'est il suffit pas il suffit pas
qu'il y en ait un qui va y rassembler il
faut que tout le monde accepte la
légitimité de cette élection qui a donné
un score net à nicolas sarkozy qui s'est
déroulée dans des conditions sereines et
qui tourne la page je le dis des
divisions de 2012 2013 et qui doit
tourner sans même pécresse
vous êtes une proche de françois fillon
et vous avez apporté votre soutien à
monsieur sarkozy pour cette élection à
la présidence de l'ump
êtes vous le connaissez bien vous avez
été sa ministre
si je vous demande en deux mots de
l'écrire deux qualifiés monsieur sarkozy
qu'est ce que vous diriez en deux mots
de qualificatifs aujourd'hui ouais je
dirais dynamique et je dirai et je
dirais entraînant entraînant c'est un
mot important parce que ça veut dire que
il a cette capacité à remettre en
mouvement une famille politique qui est
quand même marqué par deux en charge de
qualité qui ont toujours été les siennes
tourner le reconnais mais il n'a pas
chaussé admis et ses ennemis comme ses
amis il n'a pas changé il a pris voilà
deux mots pour françois fillon
et pour françois fillon je dirais
l'honnêteté et le courage autres c'était
toujours pour la primeur à bagnols moi
je vais vous dire aujourd'hui clair moi
je ne soutiens personne pour la primaire
moi j'ai dit que 2010 est c'était 2017
on verrait en 2017 qui serait le mieux
placé pour faire gagner nos convictions
je ne suis une femme libre en revanche
en revanche je suis très proche de
françois fillon dans le diagnostic
repose sur la société française et
surtout dans les propositions qu'il
apporte j'ai eu quelques petites petit
passe d'armes avec nicolas sarkozy sur
la question des 35 heures moi
personnellement je pense qu'il faudra
augmenter le temps de travail qu'il
faudra aussi augmenter les salaires mais
qu'on pourra pas augmenter pourra pas
faire 39 heures payées 39 juste à n'est
pas réaliste a valu on a eu des sud est
des petits divergences sur la question
de la dette sur la question des
retraites
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ne faut
plus de démagogie en politique et il
faut vraiment dire la vérité et je pense
que françois fillon parle un discours de
vérité par la disco extrêmement
courageux qu'il faut entendre dans le
dans le débat politique
alors justement ça nous amène à parler
de votre parti vous de gounod d'autres
de l'identité pardon de l'identité de
votre de votre parti donc de le du jeu
je bégayais va donc en projet était vide
et oui on va donc s'attaquer au projet
et quelles sont les lignes force que
vous souhaiter pour ce projet
aujourd'hui on a on n'a de sujet c'est
comment est ce qu'on ramène la
croissance dans notre pays
vraiment on le voit les inégalités n'ont
jamais été aussi grandes je sais que
manuel valls va prononcer un discours
sur les inégalités demain moi je
voudrais lui dire très gentiment
aujourd'hui c'est les entreprises qui
créent la richesse dans notre pays et on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui faire un
environnement défavorable à la création
d'emplois or c'est ce que le
gouvernement s'emploie à faire depuis
trois ans pour prendre l'exemple de la
région ile-de-france qui est celui que
je connais le mieux
on a augmenté d'un milliard d'euros
toutes les taxes sur les parkings sur
les bureaux sur les taxes foncières
maintenant le versement transport alinéa
1 milliards d'euros de taxes
supplémentaires sur les entreprises
franciliennes qui n'en peuvent plus une
loi du flou qui gèle le logement enfin
on a une région qui en panne
on a une région qui est fracturé une
région qui est pollué par on a
l'impression que rien n'est fait pour
attirer or aujourd'hui on est dans une
compétition qui est mondial on doit
attirer les investisseurs chez nous on
doit créer un environnement pour la
croissance chez nous et c'est ça la
première ayant été la deuxième priorité
c'est comment on fait survivre le modèle
social français comment on le finance
dans ce contexte de croissance qui est
pour l'instant molle donc il faut
d'abord la croissance est ensuite sauver
le modèle social ça va être deux
priorités
j'aurai une troisième priorité si vous
me permettez l'éducation parce que notre
système éducatif est en train là aussi
de sombrer et moi je il sombre dans
l'indifférence générale avec une
université à qui on coupe les vivres
avec une école où on n'arrive plus à
recruter d'enseignants donc moi je vais
vous le dire l'éducation se
une priorité personnelle que je mettrais
au programme de nicolas seube alors ce
programme pour le réaliser comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure il faut l'unité
on a vu l'organigramme du parti est
quasiment bouclé un monsieur sarkozy a
nommé son numéro 2 son numéro 3 nathalie
kosciusko morizet sature été comme ça
l'ump le 3 est toujours été plus
important que de deux séries ton coeur
de la cité je vais avoir des ennuis avec
madame kosciusko morizet si je dis que l
a pas la même importance que monsieur
wauquiez mais bon le fait qu'elle a
réussi à avoir des commandes et des
compétences élargies de sa fraîcheur et
leur liberté de parole notamment
également bon alors on peut dire
nkm à la gauche du président pour faire
vite et puis wauquiez à la droite
comment comment est ce que il sait dans
la synthèse qu'on va réussir à faire un
programme
l'ump a toujours été diverses on avait
des centristes des libéraux des
gaullistes et souverainistes des
européens donc la diversité c'est très
bien à condition qu'ils aient un bon
chef d'orchestre et je le dis parce que
la polyphonie moi j'aime ça ma mére
corse j'aime les polyphonies mais les
polyphonies oui c'est beau la cacophonie
c'est c'est pas beau donc nous oui à la
polyphonie non à la cacophonie
on a besoin aujourd'hui que tous les
instruments de l'ump jouent à l'unisson
donc si on a des états d'âme sur
certaines positions l'ump eh bien on
peut les exprimer mes médecins watch et
et je le dis d'autant qu'ils font dans
les a plutôt à une quand même au plus
tôt alors ok mais aux deux autres parce
que la vérité c'est que la ligne de
l'ump elle va être déterminé par les
militants elle sera pas déterminée par
intel ou par un tel quel que soit son
poste sera déterminé par les référendums
et bien sûr il va falloir les faire
voter sur une ligne on va travailler on
va les faire voter sur une île je prends
un seul exemple la loi taubira la toile
tegra sur le mariage pour tous vous
savez que laurent wauquiez et pour
l'abrogation avec nathalie kosciusko et
contre l'abrogation mais entre les deux
il ya une voie moyenne qui la mienne qui
est celle de la réécriture notamment sur
les aspects de filiation moi je pense
que sur cette voie moyenne on peut
dégager un consensus à l'ump n'abroge
pas mais on réécrit une partie de la loi
sur les aspects filiation notamment pour
interdire la gpa la pma
je pense qu'on peut arriver à un
consensus mais ce ne sera ni consensus
de l'orne il consensus de l'autre et si
on arrive à cette ligne de l'ump il ya
un moment donné il faudra que chacun
dise la ligne c'est ça moi je pense
peut-être un peu différemment mais la
ligne c'est ça ai je vraiment c'est du
respect pour nos militants dont il
s'agit c'est du respect pour eux pour le
travail qu'ils font pour la fois qu'il
met en nous on doit arrêter d'avoir une
bataille d'ego on doit être au service
d'un collectif d'une équipe alors
monsieur sarkozy d'également qui veut
construire un grand parti qui veut le
reflet des et ça va être quoi ce nouveau
parti par rapport à celui qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
l'ambition aujourd'hui notre ambition ça
doit être de ramener à nous d des
nouveaux militants et 500 moi je la
dérange je suis bien placé pour vous
dire je le vois en ile de france que
beaucoup de nos adhérents écoeurés par
nos guéguerres intestines se sont
détournés de nous qui n'ont pas
réadhérer là aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
intérêt à nouveau pour l'ump parce que
l'idée c'est que nous avons un chef et
que nous avons été capables de le
désigner dans une procédure
incontestable donc ça ça va créer un
élément d'attirance et de curiosité
c'est vrai que nous avons des nouvelles
adhésions en ce moment pas mal
d'adhésion qui affluent maintenant pour
consolider ce socle cet intérêt d'aider
des électeurs et des français il faut
qu'on arrive avec des propositions
claires il faut qu'on dise qu'on fera
sur les 35 heures il faut qu'on dise
qu'on fera sur les retraites je veux
qu'on dise qu'on fera sur
l'environnement il faut qu'on dise qu'on
fera sur l'éducation
si on a mis ce coup dur c'est qu'on a
une ligne à déterminer et cette ligne
elle se déterminera sens du bien sûr sur
tous les sujets est ce que tu es colas
sarkozy a fait une campagne trop à
droite selon vous c'est ce que certains
lui reprochent vous le savez en interne
c'est la campagne qu'il a vaut mieux il
a gagné
non il ya autant d un rééquilibrage au
sommet or maintenant mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas entendu de
proposition dans cette campagne donc
aujourd'hui les propositions faut les
mettre sur la table il faut qu'on en
discute
j'ai encore deux petites questions le
changement de nom vous êtes pour vous
être contre nous pour moi le mandement
de l'ump point noir pour moi ripoliné
sans changer les pratiques ça sert à
rien donc il faut aussi des pratiques
complètement nouvelle non non non moi
moi je suis pas contre le changement à
condition que ce ne soit pas un prétexte
pour ne rien changer du tout vous avez
une idée du nom ça pour être aucune
aucune mai
je pense qu'on aussi on peut faire
preuve de créativité pourquoi pas encore
question le groupe communiste au conseil
de paris veut faire du logement social
dans le siège de l'ump rue de vaugirard
vous en pensez quoi s'il croit que les
bureaux sont inoccupés ils se trompent
et on y travaille énormément et donc je
crois qu'il devrait si elle n'est pas à
vendre
il devrait s'occuper plutôt d'un certain
nombre de lieux inoccupés moi je pense
par exemple aux au logement dans les
lycées d'île de france dont un certain
nombre sont vacants faute d'attribution
paris
alors on faut quand même qu'on dise un
mot sur les résultats de la législative
partielle dans l'eau ou à un candidat
ump va faire face à un candidat du front
national dimanche pour remplacer donc
françois baroin devenu sénateur valérie
pécresse
on a vu que le ps avait été éliminé avec
donc une nouvelle débâcle est ce que
vous imaginez un ps demain rayés de la
carte électorale
aujourd'hui on voit bien le désespoir
des électeurs des électeurs de gauche
qui se manifeste ce scrutin après
scrutin mais c'est un désespoir qui
explicable si vous voulez quand vous
avez un président de la république qui a
promis des choses et qu'il fait linverse
ou qui de promesses en promesses déçoit
ses électeurs soit sur le chômage sur la
croissance sur surtout ça vous a surtout
inquiétant pour le fonctionnement
démocratique et oui je vous trouve ça
inquiétant au fonctionnement
démocratique parce que derrière il ya la
décrédibilisation de la parole politique
et moi je me sens même quand je dois
m'adresser à des personnes qui meurent
en compte dans la rue qui me sollicitent
qui me disent qu'ils ont des problèmes
il ya une décrédibilisation de la parole
et je pense qu'on ne regagnera la
confiance bizarrement que par la base
que par les élections locales c'est
aussi pour ça que je pense qu'un combat
fondateur de 2015 parce que les maires
eux ils sont comptables quand un maire
plus une bêtise il est tout de suite
responsable que ce soit sur un trottoir
que sur une école que ce soit sur une
question de sécurité donc le maire est
tout petit responsable
et quand il prend un engagement il doit
le tenir donc c'est à partir des tissus
des élus locaux qu'on pourra
reconstruire la crédibilité du politique
merci ma belge jacky perrine tarneaud
arrive maintenant donc pour évoquer la
campagne des régionales je le disais
tout à l'heure que vous
vous allez coordonnées pour lui-même et
que vous menez déjà en ile-de-france
contre le président actuel jean paul
huchon dernier bras de fer sur les
transports même si la dernière
initiative de la majorité a tout pour
plaire aux franciliens les explications
de jérôme rabier jean paul huchon a le
sourire
il faut dire que ce matin il vient
vanter une mesure assez facile à
présenter aux franciliens la création
d'une carte navigo à tarif unique 70
euros la concrétisation d'une promesse
qu'il avait faite dans l'entre-deux
tours des élections régionales de 2010
pour rallier les écologistes à sa liste
qu'on a bataillé l'entente avec le
joueur pour avoir les financements
celle ci soit nécessaire et maintenant
le fais moi je fais ce que j'ai dit que
je ferai c'est une promesse qui va être
tenues tout simplement il aura donc
fallu cinq ans pour sa mise en place
mais la mesure est bien accueillie je
trouve que ça serait bien passe comme ça
parce que pour les banlieusards
c'est quand même intéressant
concrètement cette mesure permet d'en
finir avec la tarification par zones
le prix actuel de la carte navigo
variant de 59 euros à 113,20 euros en
fonction des distances utilisé dès
septembre 2015 tous les franciliens
payeront 70 euros pour se déplacer dans
l'ensemble de la région
si jean paul huchon est très satisfait
les écologistes rappellent que cette
idée c'est d'abord la leur
cette mesure qui était écologistes
départ au film des années au fil des
discussions le dézonage le week-end des
zonages pendant les vacances est devenue
une mesure portée par toute la majorité
est aujourd'hui à la beauty et on en est
satisfait un aboutissement qui est un
coût évalué à 400 millions d'euros par
an minimum
alors pour trouver ces fonds jean paul
huchon a fait appel aux entreprises
celles situées à paris et dans les
communes limitrophes verront leur
versement transport augmenter et près de
200 millions d'euros viendront d'un
redéploiement de budget à la région
si la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
francilienne a validé l'accord le medef
ile de france est lui opposé à cette
mise en place sur le fond c'est une
bonne mesure
simplement ce que nous pensons c'est que
c'est une mesure qui est peut être prise
en période de croissance lorsque les
entreprises ont de l'argent et que nous
avons les moyens de faire ce type de
mesures une mesure qui sera effective en
septembre 2015 trois mois seulement
avant les élections régionales et la
gauche compte bien s'en servir pour
conserver la région ile-de-france donc
manqué contrat dans la campagne aux
questions non le pass navigo unique pour
les franciliens notamment peut-être pour
les habitants de 20 départements les
yvelines avec le pass unique on a été
très nombreux à être favorables à l'idée
c'est à dire que les élites en grande
couronne paye la même chose que ceux de
la petite couronne parce qu'ils ont une
offre de transport qui est totalement
médiocre et qui ne s'est pas améliorée
dans le depuis des années alors qu'on
réclame un plan orsec transports non
c'est un cadeau empoisonné c'est un
cadeau électoral totalement polonais
parce qu'on n'a pas d'argent pour le
payer parce que ça vous coûte pas du
tout 400 millions d'euros comme on le
dit ça coûte 550 millions d'euros
c'était la dernière étude qui a été
faite en 2011 qui disait qu'il fallait
trouver 550 millions pour le faire et
jean paul huchon lui-même avait dit
il y a quelques années quand nous étions
en débat aux écologistes
il lui avait dit cet argent nous ne
l'avons pas et cet argent si je ne peux
pas le prendre sur les investissements
transport qui sont absolument
indispensables le mans il a mis quatre
ans pour trouver cet argent
bien sûr que non il n'a pas trouvé vous
avez vous vendu vent madame il nous dit
il dit qu'il va trouver sa part
régulièrement mais bien sûr et à toutes
les sombres personne ne peut ne pourra
vérifier ses dires puisqu'il va faire
entrer ce pass navigo en vigueur au 1er
octobre 2015 alors que les élections
sont dans des centres personne ne pourra
vérifier si la halle cet argent alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer merveilleux
arguments de campagne pour lui il n'est
pas divisible mais pas eu le temps de
partir pour un quatrième mandat mais pas
du tout parce que je pense que les
franciliens vont se rendre compte qu'à
un moment donné il ya quelqu'un qui doit
payer la facture
et si c'est pas l'usagé qui paye c'est
donc le contribuable ou alors si je
tente alors une emprise les entreprises
les entreprises ne payeront les
entreprises ne paieront que 200 millions
d'euros il manque 300 millions d'euros à
trouver sur le budget d'ile-de-france
vous dit que ce sont les contribuables
après les élections régionales est le
jeudi 6 rue d'isly peillon
de deux choses il faudra que quelqu'un
paye donc de deux choses l'une soit jean
paul huchon sacrifiera les
investissements transport qui sont
absolument urgent et nécessaire je vous
rappelle que les usagers sont contre
cette mesure
les associations d'usagers on dit
c'était une fausse bonne idée parce que
ce qui ce dont ils avaient besoin
c'était de transport neuf de nouvelles
lignes d'aidé train chauffé des trains
éclairé et donc de confort et des trains
qui arrivent à l'heure ils ont dit nous
voulons du la qualité de service pas la
baisse des tarifs s'est accélérée ces
tarifs qui finance le savez bien c'est
pas des élèves et les voyageurs qui
kiffent qui finance les infrastructures
vertes au 13ème rang des jeunes majeurs
vous rigolez si on vous en les 500
millions de financement par les saristes
d'autre part dont 300 millions de trou
en deux ans et la rénovation d'un erreur
ça veut dire que en deux ans vous
dépensez en baisse de tarifs le
finançons derrière moi ce que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'effectivement c'est
un cadeau électoral démagogique mais
empoisonnée et derrière il faut trouver
300 millions d'euros alors moi je dis
que monsieur valls gouvernement qui a
approuvé la mise en place de ce parce
qu'il a béni qui a autorisé
l'augmentation de la fiscalité
d'entreprise devra payer
la facture des 300 millions d'euros
c'est pas à la région de sacrifier les
investissements seront les contribuer à
l'est pas ce n'est pas à la région de
payer et ça n'est pas la région
d'augmenter ne veux pas je ne veux pas
que la région soit obligé de l'opinion
d'un manuel vals je demande d'abord
avait une pollution qui va payer
et comme il sera incapable de me
répondre je dis que ce n'est pas au
contribuable francilien ni à la région
de payer et ce n'est pas nos
investissements qui voit ses procès en
tout cas avec cette mesure jean paul
huchon semble bien reparti pour une
nouvelle campagne électorale pour les
régionales illégitime à postuler pour un
quatrième mandat à la tête de l'île de
france
oui j'avais lu dans les statuts du parti
socialiste que c'était interdit de
réinvestir pour un quatrième mandat mais
je vois que les statuts sont faits pour
être bafouée et que vraisemblablement
jean paul huchon sera candidat il aura à
répondre de 17 ans de bilan et je suis
désolé mais de vous dire que pour tous
ceux qui prennent les transports pour
tous ceux qui cherchent à se loger
aujourd'hui pour tous ceux qui cherchent
un emploi l'île de france est une région
en panne je les dis c'est une région
fracturée c'est la région l'une des plus
polluées alors le bilan de 17 ans de
gouvernement socialistes et verts
permettez moi de vous dire qu'il est
particulièrement calamiteux vous allez
incarner la liste a priori pour l'ump
alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait un ticket
guaino douillet qui sembleraient se
former est-ce qu'il va y avoir une
primaire au sein de l'ump pour la tête
de liste pour les régionales en
ile-de-france un côté moi je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de quoi que ce soit je
trace mon sillon je suis mon engagement
écoutez il ya une rumeur par semaine je
travaille ce qui était rapporté le
public m'a écouté j'attends j'attends
d'avoir plus de précisions en tout cas
david douillet a demandé à être la
candidate naturelle est incontournable
je vais vous dire c'est pas comme ça que
je raisonne mermoud engagement il est
authentique ça fait quatre ans que je
sillonne cette région pour en résoudre
les problèmes en tant que opposante
j'ai résolu un problème de manque de
matériel sur le rer d c'est moi qui je
les trouvais des rames à vendre en
nord-pas de calais c'est moi qui me suis
battu pour les bourses des infirmières
c'est moi qui me suis battu pour le
tramway qui arrive à vélizy châtillon
pour recapitaliser l'entreprise lors
qu'il faisait faillite
donc je me bats au quotidien pour les
franciliens je me bats depuis quatre ans
il n'y a rien de calculé d'opportunisme
tout est authentique et sincère dans mon
engagement est d'ailleurs david douillet
m'a demandé d'être de faire tandem avec
moi dans les yvelines
donc je suis désolé de vous le dire que
ça bat en brèche un tout petit peu votre
donc vous serez bien la candidate de
l'ump pour les régionales en quêté je
suis candidate je serai candidate pour
être chargé de coordonner cette campagne
pour l'ump donc a priori vous avez le
poste pour superviser l'ensemble y
compris villes de france en tout cas je
mettrai toute mon savoir faire mon
engagement et ma connaissance du fait
régional au service de ma famille
politique
alors quelques questions d'actualité
pour finir cette émission quelques
questions aussi et parisiennes et
franciliennes
tout d'abord la vente de 49 9% du
capital de l'aéroport de toulouse par
l'état à un consortium chinois
est-ce que c'est légitime selon vous
font je suis un peu perplexe sur 7 sur
cette vente parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on nous dissimule des choses on nous
dit ne vous inquiétez pas ils sont pas
majoritaires et puis on nous dit ah mais
finalement il ya un pacte d'actionnaires
qui fait qu'en réalité de fait ils sont
majoritaires donc moi ce que j'aime pas
c'est qu'on avance masqué si le
gouvernement accueille des investisseurs
chinois qui le disent qu'il est
j'allais dire l'honnêteté la sincérité
de dire la vérité aux français qu'ils
n'essayent pas de la masquer mois est ce
qu'on peut vendre un aéroport à des
investisseurs étrangers sont que le bois
est assez partagée je suis un désastre
et et je suis voilà exactement c'est ce
que je vais vous dire il ya des actifs
qui sont stratégiques
anne aéroports notamment à toulouse dans
une région qui est connu pour sa
recherche spatial aéronautique pour des
activités qui sont des activités
j'allais dire sensible parfois avec des
applications militaires
je suis dubitative sur le bien fondé de
cette vente
on avance avec le tacle du jour qui est
signée ségolène royal qui jugent absurde
la décision d'anne hidalgo d'interdire
les feux de cheminée est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ségolène royal mais
c'est pas une décision d'anne hidalgo
c'est une c'est un décret s'il me semble
donc le gouvernement à la française
écoutez moi ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que moi je considère effectivement
est fléché le clézio le dit
sur à de nombreuses reprises que cette
interdiction des feux de cheminée est
juste absurde elle est absurde parce que
ça me fait penser à vous savez ces
écologistes qui disent la couche d'ozone
et troué par la méthanisation des
ruminants qui donc il faudrait qu'on
mange plus de viande pour qui les moines
bages pour qu'ils aient moins de trous
dans la couche d'ozone tout à fait faux
oui mesdames et scientifiquement c'est
certainement faux si vous voulez
scientifiquement c'est pas faux
scientifiquement bien entendu comme les
feux de cheminée créer des films
regardés faux nom mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'il ya un gars chaix
concernant la pollution de l'air à paris
voilà la dégradation de la qualité de
l'air comme l'alcool la dégradation de
la couche d'ozone ne sont pas du tout
nos vaches nées au feu de cheminée et
donc on ne va pas mais non mais c'est ça
la vérité donc la vérité c'est qu'on a
des polluants et c'est ce contre ces
polluants qui font les polluants dont
les polluants permettez-moi de le dire
il ya le plan de circulation à paris le
plan de circulation
monsieur delanoë paris le plan de
circulation de monsieur delanoë des
verts à paris a créé des embouteillages
india - voiture dans la capitale depuis
l'armée mais moins de voitures ne veut
pas dire moins de pollution chers amis
quand les voitures sont à l'arrêt dans
des embouteillages
eh bien il ya plus de pollution il est
malheureusement la pollution à
paris-xiii lavera grave et oui et donc
est donc aujourd'hui on répare en
interdisant les cheveux de cheminée une
citation qu'on a nous mêmes créé que la
position apparaît enfin qu'on a nous
mêmes la lamelle et maire de paris et
anne hidalgo qui veut interdire
maintenant à partir de 2020 toutes les
voitures qui roulent au diesel dans
paris le prouver sur sept qui sont des
voitures des ailes moi je vais vous dire
je directement les habitants de banlieue
par exemple moi je pense qu'on ne peut
pas prendre des mesures dans paris intra
muros il ya une forme d'égoïsme parisien
qui est juste plus acceptable pour tous
ceux qui n'habitent pas pareil je suis
désolé de vous dire que si paris est
traversée par des voitures c'est aussi
parce qu'il n'y a pas de transports en
commun et on revient au passe navigo à
tarif unique voilà quand on quand on n'a
pas l'argent pour investir et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas assez
d'argent pour investir dans le grand
paris le gouvernement ne met pas cet
argent quand on n'a pas assez d'argent
pour investir les transports en commun
ou ne peut pas autoriser la maire de
paris à piétonniser unilatéralement tout
un quartier
moi je ne suis pas contre mais tous ces
décisions alors se prendre à l'échelle
de l'art
jouer de france il n'est pas possible
qu'un maire puisse le maire de paris
prennent des décisions qui auront un
impact totalement défavorable sur toute
la région et sur la question des diesels
n'oublions pas qu'il ya énormément de
familles modestes qui roulent en diesel
parce que c'est moins cher et donc on ne
peut pas sans transition qu'ils n'ont
pas mouillé même secteu mans donc on ne
peut pas sans transition proclamé la fin
du diesel sans une compensation très
forte pour les familles modestes les
artisans les commerçants qui utilisent
le disent elle parce que c'était moins
cher et parce qu'on a artificiellement
une promu le disant que j'avais à benoît
y ait le pouvoir d'année d'algos dans un
grand paris et que vous vous seriez peut
être la maîtresse avec d'autres à l'ump
non mais je crois que moi je crois au
dialogue et je crois au rassemblement je
crois dans ma famille politique je crois
au niveau régional je pense qu'on ne
peut plus jouer cavalier seul dans une
région de 12 millions d'habitants qui a
vocation avec la région capitale c'est
paris et ile de france
d'ailleurs que ce soit sur les jeux
olympiques où on s'aperçoit qu'on a
besoin l'île de france que ce soit sur
l'exposition universelle
la vérité c'est qu'il ya pas différence
c'est qu'on vit à paris on travaille à
en banlieue on vit en banlieue on
travaille à paris nous
j'allais dire nous nous enrichissons
mutuellement et il ne peut pas y avoir
les riches au centre et les
laissés-pour-compte à la périphérie et
je me battrai contre ces fractures toute
dernière question est ce qu'il faut ou
non interdire les crèches dans les lieux
publics
quand vous dites les crèches les crèches
de noël oui parce que ce que j'ai le
moment le cidrier
regardez les enfants retourner à la
maison garde les ans c'est mon service
et c'était à propos de la burqa est ce
que donc dans la logique effectivement
il faut aussi éviter qu'il y ait des
records nationaux religieuses comme la
crèche de noël dans les édifices publics
à la mairie
max et moi je vais venir en matière de
laïcité il peut pas y avoir deux poids
deux mesures le premier ministre ne peut
pas nous dire sur les crèches on
applique la loi et sur la burqa c'est
pas grave si on n'applique pas donc moi
j'attends qu'ils aient une position
claire et cette position sicile respect
intégral de la loi ça doit l'être et
pour les crèches et pour la burqa on ne
sacrifiera pas les traditions et au
profit d'autres oui parce qu'après les
crashs verra la galette des rois au mois
de janvier la galette des rois les
arbres de noël parce que c'est quand
même bizarre de l'hiver enfin bon et il
ya un vrai sujet soit noël
merci d'avoir été avec no mercy perrine
pensera tout ça très vite